the buddies thing about kids is they
they don't think that we experience what
they experience like we were teenagers
we did what you did like they think oh
you wouldn't understand oh no like he
thinks he's the only person who ever
broke something in a house and just
pretended like it ever happened
go ahead do that you guys never do that
chick will you brave something when
you're a kid you just throw the pieces
out like if there's like that lamp never
existed but like your parents two
grown-ups are gonna walk into the living
room and just notice that that's one of
the two lamps that isn't there that's
how dumb teenagers are they're dumb as
[ __ ] I dropped a keg on a hardwood floor
in my house growing up when my parents
were out of town we had a party it was
the dining room I just slid the dining
room table and rug over nine inches like
gold they'll never notice it's the first
thing my mom noticed when she walked in
she was like why is the table there but
how'd you notice she was like I'm a
grown-up now we all know pitfalls of
being a teenager right so you have to
decide which ones you want to warn your
kids about and how you should warn them
you know I think we've all changed how
we warn our kids about drinking and
driving now it's the message is easy
call an uber calling it a lift I'll pay
for everything but there's no excuse for
it to ever happen you know and I know
all the people that I don't have kids
are very vocal about that now and I
don't know too many teenage kids that
are drinking and driving anymore because
of that right we're pretty clear on this
message now and but there's other things
that you don't you you know they're
gonna run into that you don't tell them
about because how would you like my
daughter look one of the pitfalls that I
knew my daughter was gonna run into my
daughter my princess my baby girl the
smartest young woman that I know but I
knew that my daughter my baby girl you
know what pitfall I knew she was gonna
fall for you knew it I knew she was
gonna fall for I knew that my daughter
was gonna fall for just the tip how did
I know she was gonna fire
because you fell for and you fell for it
and you fell for it and you fell for the
old [ __ ] fell for something if he
didn't fall for just the Tim you fell
for I just want to lay naked next to you
just one pump I want to know what it
feels like
don't shake your [ __ ] hands you all
felt for something and that's what I
knew I'm like she's gonna fall for that
[ __ ] and by the way it's not that I
don't want her to have sex I'm not that
guy who's like oh I know that's gonna
happen but the tip is where the bad
stuff comes from the tip makes me make
babies I don't want that [ __ ] I don't
want babies I'd rather have a guy say
just the nuts fine dude suck your nuts
in there I got no problem of that stump
nuts I'm in a bit I'm gonna run for
office I'm your stuff nuts lips like
feels great stuff nuts no kids that's
all I'm saying it's so funny to see them
do [ __ ] that I did I remember the first
time I found my son drunk in my kitchen
my oldest son and here's the thing he
was here's how you can tell someone's
drunk you can tell they're drunk by what
two foods they're combining together
because if you're eating chips and salsa
you're not that drunk he was dipping
chicken into peanut butter sitting in
the corner of the kitchen like this
[Music]
but even said I think this is now they
discovered Reese's so I was like hey man
get put the chicken in the peanut butter
down
get upstairs dudes this is embarrassing
okay
and he goes upstairs and I was way up
the stairs I said to him hey just so you
don't man not chicken and peanut butter
that's not gonna be good for you later
and I was right because I heard that
we've all heard that right that
late-night run to the bathroom your body
is amazing your body is amazing for this
reason you can pass out as some Peart as
a man I passed out dudes have put their
nuts on my cheek they've traced their
digs on my forehead they squirt [ __ ] all
over you you don't wake up but you got a
puke and your body's like back then send
you off running in a direction right so
I hear running down the hallway and then
there's silence and then I just hear
[Music]
this isn't fun anymore silence and then
just in my favorite I swear and then he
did a couple of what I like to call my
favorite the silent scream you know when
you're like oh I feel so good I don't so
much I hope that never have of that but
your abs never look better that next day
right like I need to do some more of
those
[Music]
you